partisan consensus in Washington has
been that America ought to give amnesty
to all illegal aliens within our borders
no matter how many there are the
leadership of both parties believes this
the problem is that voters definitely
don't believe it they strongly disagree
and have for decades they've said so in
polling consistently but instead of
paying attention to what the public
wants as usual the parties ignore it and
instead work together to do what they
want by stealth
their latest gambit is called HR 50:38 a
bill called the farm workforce
Modernization Act of 2019
as usual the name is Orwellian the bill
does not modernize America's
agricultural workforce in fact just the
opposite HR 50:38 is designed to keep
our farming practices primitive and
dependent upon low-wage manual labor the
bill which remarkably has a total of 24
Republican co-sponsors would give
amnesty to illegal immigrant farm
workers the United States pretty much
all of them even illegal aliens who've
been convicted of crimes would be
eligible for permanent residency here
and eventually citizenship beneficiaries
would not have to pay any back taxes
they qualify even if they skipped court
hearings or snuck back into the u.s.
after being deported don't you try
something like that as a US citizen
Congress will have no mercy on you
but for foreign nationals no problem how
many foreign nationals would benefit
from this act if it became law well in
point of fact nobody knows the pro
amnesty group farmworker justest
estimates that at least 1.2 million
illegal immigrants would be eligible but
if history is any guide and it is the
actual number would be far far higher
and that's assuming the bill would
restrict the embassy to actual farm
workers good luck with that
HR 50:38 imposes very low document
standards those applying for amnesty can
submit all kinds of different documents
there's no penalty for fraud in other
words there'd be no reason not to submit
a bogus application needless to say many
people would just as they did 30 years
ago during the Ronald Reagan amnesty
that's supposedly limited farm worker
amnesty drew hundreds of thousands of
fraudulent applications and here's the
key most of them were approved anyway in
some cases even illegal immigrants who
arrived in
this country after amnesty became law
we're allowed to benefit from the
amnesty think about that for a minute it
was a joke
now they want to do it again but on a
much larger scale so to sum up the farm
workforce modernization act of 2019
would reward law breaking exacerbate the
border crisis and undermine the already
stalled wages of American blue-collar
workers it's pretty much the mirror
image the exact opposite of what Donald
Trump ran on just three years ago and
yet members of Congress like Ally
Stefanik Tom call fred Upton and more
than 20 other Republicans are now
fighting to make it law why is that
you've got to wonder maybe they're not
bright enough to know what's in the bill
maybe there's some other motive maybe
someone should ask them